Speaker 1: . I want to look at two very short
clips here from MyPillow CEO and founder
Mike Lindell. As I hope you know, by now, his
predictions are garbage. He was predicting
in November and December of 2020 that before
January 6th, the election would flip to Biden.
I'm sorry, would flip to Trump, and it didn't.
And then between January 6th and January 20th,
he was predicting something would happen to
prevent Joe Biden from being inaugurated.
And it didn't happen. And then he predicted it
would happen in March, April, and then it would
be by the start of summer and then the end of
summer and then by Thanksgiving. And then here we
are in March of 2022, and it hasn't happened. His
new thing is he will be filing a lawsuit to ban
all voting machines. I know, guys,
I know. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: You got a class action lawsuit that's
coming out, hopefully by next week. We're getting
our best shot at to make the machines take it.
It's the most important class action lawsuit in
American history and world history, right?
Speaker 1: This is more important than
when companies leak leak toxic chemicals into
waterways, and it causes cancer. This is bigger
than the class action lawsuits against tobacco
companies that have led to so many deaths.
This is the biggest. Come on,
Speaker 4: get rid of the machines concerned.
They're considered defective devices. That's
what the lawsuit is a defective product.
Speaker 1: Either way, what is the lawsuit mean
Speaker 4: and brakes on a car? Brian,
when you get a car and you're driving down the
road, you expect to get you to point A to point
B if you turn to the right and it goes like this
could affect you, right? Well, we've been working
on this lawsuit for five months now and it's ready
to launch. We are. I've been saying to my station,
great TV brings, brings TV. We we read.
Speaker 1: She
seems confused by what he's saying and out of
breath. I mean, every aspect of this is cuckoo
Speaker 4: till the call, the county commissioners
and county clerks in the country to get on board
this class-action lawsuit. We have a list of over
300 of that's three out of three thousand county.
Speaker 1: What do you think it's like to be so
delusional? Like, what do you think it's
like to be so disconnected from reality?
Speaker 4: You only need a couple, but they're
jumping on board and Trump, you're watching after
you guys can go to great speech dot com and go
down. There's a form there. You fill out email
my team, will you think, get on board with this?
Speaker 1: What does it even mean to get on board
like if I want to get on board with his lawsuit if
I go too far? What's even at frank speech? Yeah,
it's not. There's not really even anything here.
Like it's not even clear you can do anything,
just a complete and total fantasy world. I mean,
complete now. He also spoke at a fundraiser for
Republican candidate Kerry Lake, and he talked
about it there. And here he said it's it's a
lawsuit against all machines. OK, here.
Speaker 4: I'm going to tell you right
now we're doing I've been
working on it for five months.
Yeah, and we're doing a class
action. I'm announcing it here.
I noticed it on my program. We all watch Frank
Speech dot com. Okay. Keep watching. And they.
But it's a class action
lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: That's just that's even funnier because
I know he means voting machines. But when Pillow
says it's a he. Your law. Your your dishwasher.
Is about to be legal, hell is about to rain down
on your dishwasher. If you thought that your
toaster was free and clear, he is filing an
injunction against the toaster. If you've
been wondering why isn't bagel mode working?
He's suing. He's suing over all machines, guys
Speaker 4: that they're defective devices. Yes.
I have lawyers worked on this for five months.
We're getting county commissioners, county clerks,
they're all the plaintiffs, and we've
already got about 300 of them born.
And we're going to get rid of
these machines once and for all.
Speaker 1: Good old Mike Pillow. He's
simultaneously a complete and total clown,
but also a MAGA hero. And that's
really kind of the same thing.